bonjour à tous alors nous sommes ici
devant la grotte des fées ce dolmen
digne des albums d'astérix et obélix
pourtant nous ne sommes pas en armorique
mais en touraine à une dizaine de
kilomètres au nord de tours alors
pourquoi trouve-t-on des mégalithes ici
c'est ce que nous allons tenter de
savoir c'est parti
[Musique]
au milieu des champs caché entre les
arbres se dresse un vestige millénaire
classé monument historique le dolmen de
la grotte aux fées
un jour il ya longtemps et eu un orage
la nuit et les faits en construit ce
domaine en une nuit pour s'abriter de
l'orage et l on dit que si quelqu'un
prenez ces pierres pour construire des
maisons ou des routes la personne
mourrait dans l'année aujourd'hui encore
on verrait danser c'est fait la nuit
tout autour du dolmen l'effet chante
aller les faits danse et vous voyez
saisi fla bon c'est pas la saison mais
il ya des petites boules rouges sur les
ifs et on dit que ce sont les les perles
de sueur des faits qui danse toute la
nuit et qui viennent s'accrocher sur les
ifs
on attribue à cette construction au fait
car ont mis longtemps à comprendre
comment les hommes du néolithique ont pu
bâtir ce mégalithes de 11 mètres de long
le plus important de touraine et
pourtant juste avec des cordes des
rondins de bois une rampe
ils ont réussi à installer cette pierre
d'environ 50 tonnes sa construction sa
date entre eux disons d'une manière très
large entre 5000 avant jésus-christ et
2200 avant jésus-christ à environ on a
trouvé des fragments d'ossements humains
on a trouvé des fragments d'ossements
onu animaux on a trouvé des petites
lames en silex la plupart du temps à ce
sont des endroits où on inhument les
morts là étant donné qu'il ya très peu
de deux corps qui ont été déposés ici on
peut supposer que c'était sûr au
sûrement les personnages les plus
importants de cette époque et de ceux de
ce secteur
mais aujourd'hui des fissures
apparaissent sur ses bases et à
l'intérieur la pierre s'effrite
après plusieurs milliers d'années sur
terre le dolmen et donc fragilisés est
ce que ce serait pas le feu qui ferait
éclater les pierres c'est bien
évidemment le feu jadis on pouvait tenir
debout bon et pour éviter un petit peu
que des gens viennent s'abriter pique
nique et allumé des feux ça a été
remblayé et voyez on peut plus se tenir
debout mais ça suffit pas il y aurait la
solution de bêtes une clôture
moi j'ai vu ça déjà en bretagne
[Musique]
attention à vous qui osez ébranlé ces
pierres vous pourriez bien déclenché la
colère des faits et de saint-antoine du
rocher alors pourrait plus loin au sujet
des mégalithes et des légendes autour de
ces monuments
nous sommes avec jacky des prix et donc
vous êtes prêt historien et spécialiste
des mégalithes ici dans la région quand
on regarde une carte schématique de la
france la présence des mégalithes c'est
vrai qu'on le voit plus entre la
bretagne et l'anjou jusqu'à l'aveyron
mais moi en région centre val de loire
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y en a ici c'est
qu'il y en a depuis le 19e siècle à peu
près la moitié qui ont disparu il y en
avait énormément et il n'y a pas de
raison alors évidemment ou ne connaît
aujourd'hui que ceux qui restent
la deuxième raison c'est que ici on peut
avoir des matériaux pour les construire
nous sommes sur les eaux du versant de
la vallée de l'a6 où la roche calcaire à
fleurs et par conséquent les hommes
préhistoriques de l'époque qu'on appelle
les néolithique ou ont pu
s'approvisionner en grande dalle est la
construction de ces monuments a
longtemps été un mystère parce qu'on se
disait comment est-ce qu'ils aient pour
fabriquer pour monter ses pierres de
plusieurs dizaines de tonnes et
justement ça a créé beaucoup de légendes
avec gargan de soi avec les faits je
serais aujourd'hui encore même si on
commence par les légendes on en a
effectivement un certain nombre ici qui
sont d'époque différentes les plus
anciennes évidemment disent que ce sont
les faits qui ont construit ces
monuments pour l'époque médiévale on a
affaire évidemment à gargantua qui en se
coincent à chaussures faisait tomber
effectivement des cailloux qui jalonnent
la vallée de la 6 os et surtout que ce
sont des premiers éleveurs agriculteurs
il ya à peu près six mille ans qui ont
construit ces monuments en récupérant
localement les pierres les transportant
sur des rondins de bois
et puis en construisant ses monuments
qui était destiné devenir des sépultures
collectives
merci beaucoup jacky des prier pour
toutes les explications je vous quitte
au milieu de ce dolmen classé monument
historique à la chapelle vendômoise
appelé la pierre le
v ou encore la table du diable vous
l'aurez compris le diable les faits ou
autres sorciers font partie de
l'imaginaire du centre val de loire
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce tour
d'horizon non exhaustif du patrimoine et
de ses légendes et je vous dis à très
bientôt
[Musique]